voici ce qu'il reste du scot semaine un
grand voilier de la marine marchand qui
a sombré dans le fleuve saint laurent en
1846 une épave de 25 m très bien
conservés protégés par la noirceur et
les eaux glaciales du fleuve pour un
archéologues subaquatiques c'est une
pièce de collection
c'est comme un des derniers témoins de
la grande navigation à voile la
navigation transatlantique en fait on
est au même moment où il ya déjà les
grands les vapeurs convoi jusqu'aux
grands lacs le développement de montréal
la vapeur commence après nominés mais il
reste quelques navires comme ça un petit
peu partout au monde qui continue de
faire les traversé le mondial
le scot mêmes propriétés de riches
marchands écossais de montréal a coulé
au large du bic dans la région de
rimouski un jour de tempête il y avait
neuf membres d'équipage ils ont ils
avaient deux chaloupes probablement ils
ont essayé de mettre les chaloupes à la
maison l'ennemi ils sont sortis du
bateau avant qui coule mais un seul
survivant un groupe d'archéologues a
visité scotsman à trois reprises depuis
2000 18 ans documents dans tout ce
qu'ils ont découvert
l'objectif utilisé cette matière
première pour offrir une deuxième vie
aux bateaux une vie virtuelle que le
design qu'on a choisi de faire avec
l'application de réalité virtuelle c'est
bien mettre les gens dans les souliers
les archéologues subaquatiques
l'intelligence artificielle et les
techniques 3d permettent aujourd'hui de
reproduire les conditions dans
lesquelles travaillent les archéologues
à 30 mètres de profondeur
une fois programmé le casque de réalité
virtuelle va simuler l'univers
sous-marin de l'épave est qu en la faune
aquatique
une démo net servira de l'an portative
l'autre de plans détaillés de lait par
quatre utilisateurs pourront explorer le
scot semaine en même temps les familles
vont pouvoir déambuler dans cette loi en
marchant ils vont vraiment marcher
autour des vestiges il voit dans une
salle plus au mètre carré et ils vont
marcher à travers l'épave en regardant
que lampe de poche un archéologue
virtuel comme entre les objets et la
faune de l'épave découvert par les
apprentis plongeurs
c'est pour obliger les gens à chercher
s'approcher regardé comme du monde qui
donc est en contact avec les vestiges
puis en même temps se rend compte que
c'est pas facile parce qu'il ya du
plancton dans ta face tu vois rien le
scotsman virtuelle sera intégrée à
l'exposition du musée maritime du québec
à l'islet dans chaudière-appalaches si
quelques mois on ce qu'on fait c'est un
petit peu pour aussi de moderniser en
fait notre propre discipline qui est
assez classique de prise de notes de
photos de plans qui sont toujours
intéressants qui sont qu'on va toujours
qu'on est de faire mais c'est
intéressant de les combiner avec ses
techniques là on compte éventuellement
l'offrir aux résoudre bibliothèque du
québec en apport voulu facture des
tactiques ou de werber ou dont tu vis tu
vis que celle et archéologue savoie un
site et déjà regarder ces carrières si
certains pièces tournées vers la science
et pour se rendre compte que la science
vous êtes c'est presque indiana jones
si normal grondin radio canada montréal